Eh bien bonjour !
Nous sommes avec aujourd'hui avec Carlito , Mcfly et le Grand JD !
Ouaiiiis ! Et un maximum d'ambiance dans ce studio !
Holala , Le bigdil , bienvenue dans le bigdil !
(Rires)
Les amis , aujourd'hui nous sommes sur un jeux très amusant
C'est un jeux qui s'appelle Use Your Words
En gros , on va avoir des séquences de film , des photos , des articles de journal , de tout ça
Et y'aura pas de sous titres et ce sera à nous de légender le truc
C'était clair ou c'était de la merde ?
C'était bien , ouais , bien
Nickel !
Bon d'façon le meilleur moyen de faire comprendre le jeu aux gens , c'est d'y jouer !
Bravo !!! Hoooo!!
Hoooo!!
Le mec à des phrases d'animateur de supermarché
Est-ce que vous êtes prêt ?
Ouaiiis ! Alors on y va !
C'est un film récent apparemment
Très récent
(Rires) C'est parfait !
Donc là les amis on a 1 min 30 pour  chacun trouver une phrase à sous-titrer c'est parti !
J'lai pas j'lai pas j'lai pas !
Mec prends le temps qu'il faut
Ok vas-y j'ai tenté un truc c'est pas très amusant mais abonnez-vous
Attends ( Rires)
Ha la y'a la vraie version
Ha ça c'est la vraie version ouais
D'accord, ou un mec d'entre nous qui est vraiment pas drôle
(Rires)
(Rires) Ha c'est bien ! Ha c'est moi !
Ca vous à plu ?
Ouais c'est bien , elle est bien
Merci les gars
(Rires)
Putain !
Ouah c'est tellement une bonne idée !
C'est toi ?! Ha il s'est autocité!
(Rires)
He mec c'est le seul mec quand il est pas inspiré il est génial
Il fait oui !
J'peut faire une phrase d'animateur un peu nulle ?
Et ce n'est que le début le meilleur est à venir !
Le bonheur
Ha il faut , Ho non les gars
Ouah mais ça va être dangereux ce genre de chose
Allez les gars faut montrer
(La danse de Mcfly)
J'ai rien j'ai rien je recommence
(La danse de Squeezie et Mcfly)
Ho j'arrive pas les gars j'suis paumé la !
J'ai rien j'ai rien !
Ho c'est horrible ce que vous faites j'suis concentré sur votre choré
Ok on y va !
( Rires) Qui a mis ça ?!
Qui a mis ça ? , C'est moi , Hoooooo
Quand ton pote te dit sur une photo "reste naturel" (Rires)
Celle-ci elle est bien !
La promo !
(Rires)
(Rires) C'est pas mal
Les gars nouvelle épreuve !
C'est un film les gars allez !
Allez ! Allez on y va !
Aaaaah !
Les extraits sont fous
Putain c'est dur la
Mais mec j'suis queblo
Ha ça ma fait ça avant
Oh mec je bloque tellement !
J'en ai plusieurs mais je sais pas laquelle mettre ...
Oh le mec il a le choix quoi
Hooo le mec
Ok j'ai mis un truc nul , j'ai mis un truc bien
Ok j'suis desolé j'suis obligé de vous dire un truc
C'est fou ce qui va se passer
Ha ouais ? , des barres
(Rires)
Ca c'est Carlito
Et vous allez trouver le mien
Il est la le mien
Sans se consulter mec
Oooooh !
(Rires)
Mes pecs ils sont pas flasques ok ?!
Ha c'est vrai c'est vrai je me suis trompé
Ok
Oh la vache , on est d'accord ils font pipi là les deux
Ouais
Enfin ouais y'en a un qui est attiré par le pipi de l'autre hein hooo
C'est quoi ça papa ? Et bien c'est un ver de terre.. Et bah dis donc il a une grosse bite ce verre de terre (Rires)
Ho oui ca j'aime ça
Wow (Rires)
C'est pas mal
C'est moi
La même idée quoi !
Woooohh! t'a mis ma gomme dans ton prépuce papa !!
(Rires)
oohhhh
Tellement easy putain !
Ha ouais Sub The Title
Un film , un film , allez allez
(Rires) Ho putain !
Ho putain !
Ho j'en ai un fou la !
Ho putain j'ai des trucs , la j'en ai un génial
(Rires)
Facile !
Jolie !
Ho bien jouée , c'est biien
(Rires)
C'est qui ça ?
C'est Carlito
Pffff
Bwaaaaah (Rires)
On le reconnait !
Que ?? Pourquoi mettre que ?
Ok on se concentre !
Ho j'en ai un ! J'en ai un ! Ok
*danse* JD fait vite stp
Ca fait mal aux jambes , ça fait mal aux genoux , allez putain JD la !
(Rires) Ouaiiiiis ouaiiis !
C'est qui ?! C'est ouam !
(Rires)
Ho joliiie !
Hoo ils se sont tous mis en masse !
Ho putain !
Jolie ! Qui veut à boire ?!
Moi moi moi ! Vous me dites hein , mets moi un truc à boire
Ouaaah elles sont fraiches de ouff
Haa moi j'ai pas de bière ?
(Rires)
Putain , Oh mon dieu !! C'est dur !
Oh mais mec mais c'est dur la !
C'est très dur la
ooooh
Ok *souffle*
C'était pas évident voila
J'suis passé par plusieurs étapes de réflexion dans ma tête
Au début j'étais sûr de moi
Après j'ai complètement vrillé
J'ai eu des doutes mais est-ce que c'est pas humain d'avoir des doutes hein ?
On a 2 facultés nous les humains
C'est : l'adaptation aux contexte environnant et les doutes
Heuu ta gueule ?
Ouais
Oh merde !
Merde j'ai pas vue qu'il disait ça !
Elle est très bien celle-là
Qui à mis ça ? Moi
Hoo c'est bien ! Ho merci putain les gars !
(Rires) Ho putain !! Elle est belle !
(Rires)
C'est qui ça ? J'veut savoir
Qui c'est (Rires)
Nan! C'est pas vrai ! C'est toi !
Carlito , j'crois c'est la fin de ta carrière
J'te dis un truc c'était vraiment pas bien j'pensais que c'était JD
(Rires)
Salopard
Ecoute bien (Rires)
(Rires)
Wow , Ho putain de merde
Là j'en ai plein là !
Oh jolie !! Ohhhhh
Ohh ! Jolie ! C'était très bien ça !
(Rires)
C'est toi ? Carlito..
La mienne ! La mienne !
Allez on se casse on va faire un duo
Mais ça devait être le rôle de JD ça ! ça devait pas être toi !
JD il a grave de l'impro et Carlito a pas d'impro !
C'est simple , ça fait 15 ans qu'on est pote
J'ai jamais vu ça de ma life mec
Jamais ! Ohlalala j'arrive pas hein
Oh elle est géniale ! Ohhh elle est géniale !!
J'ai la pression là
(Rires) Mais quoi !! Me regarde pas c'est lui ! Il y'a eu le fluide
(Rires) Haaaaa !!
Putain Mcfly bien vue
Bravo Mcfly !!!!
He bien les amis c'est la fin de cet vidéo en compagnie de Carlito , de Mcfly et du Grand JD
J'espère que ça vous à plu , n'hésitez pas à liker la vidéo comme d'habitude
Souscrivez un abonnement à la chaine de Mcfly et Carlito et aussi à la chaine du grand JD ici présent
Ils font d'excellentes vidéos
J'vous invite après le rayon charcuterie , allez vous abonner tout simplement et regarder leurs vidéos
Abonnez vous également à la chaîne de Lucas
Voila qui a besoin d'abonnés
Il a besoin de 10 000 abonnés
Pour accéder aux Youtube Space
Vivez votre vie prenez soin de vous et n'oubliez qu'on s'aime tous
qu'on est tous un
Carpediem
(Rires) Peace !
Ho la lumière s'est éteinte hoooooo !!!
Orthographe corrigé par Cesco
Salut C'est Lucas Moi voila je voulais juste passer pourquoi les autres et pas moi ?